une structure un peu particulière pouce
au milieu des champs un assemblage
plutôt hétéroclite pour mettre en point
où on pourrait trouver 2 2 qui s'associe
parfaitement qui s'emboîtent comme ça on
va donner de la solidité
quand matt et monica honte acheter ce
lieu les moulins de la fontaine
ils ont trouvé plus de 400 portes
fenêtres et autres volets des pièces
abandonné par l'ancien propriétaire
ils ont alors décidé de tout récupérer
pour en faire un labyrinthe des portes
et fenêtres ce toujours une connexion
entre deux espaces sa part à tout le
monde de quoi on a toujours des
souvenirs liés à des portes et les
fenêtres a des vues pourquoi des espaces
intimes au public privé et du coup ça
avait beaucoup de sens
ils ont confié la construction à
jean-philippe il a trouvé une place pour
chaque porte en fonction des matières du
style des couleurs au monte l'or et
aussi de leur histoire par exemple cette
porte là c'est la boîte de la porte de
la boîte de nuit les druides qui est
juste derrière dans le fond de la vallée
donc j'ai choisi de la placer là pour
lui donner un peu de sens quand toutes
les portes seront posées elles seront
nettoyées
certaines seront repeintes le lieu sera
leur consacrer à l'art on est sur
l'élaboration d'une oeuvre qui va
accueillir d'autres artistes qui vont
eux mêmes créé des oeuvres dessus et
puis on espère aussi que la nature va
faire son travail d'oeuvre de des
plantes vont pousser des plantes vont
attaquer les portes on espère
exposition de photographie théâtre
musique seront au programme dès la fin
septembre
[Musique]